this week on generation next we're
talking about the playstation store's
new look
more trophy changes are incoming and
we've got our textbook michael heimbach
to answer all of your final questions
about the xbox series x i'm joined by
playstation pro tomorrow hussein
absolutely dripping for new consoles
lads dripping
just drenched here water log
you know he not only went for it he kept
adding to it adding on to it
i thought he was running out of those um
no no no there's more people have people
have up are upset in the comments and to
those people i wanna
i want you to know i hear you and i
don't care
and xbox expert jordan remote hello
hello let's get into it
get in losers we're going shopping
getting loser we're going shopping
the playstation store's got a brand new
look uh tam i'm gonna come to you for
this one
so we've got a overhaul of sorts for the
playstation store
brand new layout um major things to note
from this new layout is that or the
changes to the playstation store as a
whole
is it discontinues support for ps3
psp and ps vita as well as the dlc
add-ons and the web mobile access around
that stuff
um rip to all those consoles and the
content
but if there's any consolation if you're
on those consoles
you can still buy um the content and
games using the store on there
so just make sure you're charged and all
your your details are correct and you're
good
um ps4 apps themes avatars and wishlist
have all been removed
um rest in peace to all of that nonsense
that was clogging up the store
um i think i changed my avatar maybe
once in the entire time that i have had
my ps4 did you ever use wishlist on ps4
i don't think i ever
once i did not know it existed until
right now
the only thing i can think of regarding
themes is i always get a theme that um
comes with like whatever game i'm
playing uh so one day i
went through the themes and there is a
princess diana theme on
playstation 4 and um
let's just say a lot of dashboard jokes
when i tweeted that one out
oh my god everyone like replying and
quote tweeting
but yeah if you if you want a trip go on
your ps4 console and look at the themes
look at look at the ones that like
i don't know just have a look there are
some bizarre ones in there
there's some borderline should not be on
their anime girl ones as well though i
was like how have you made it onto this
because no one's looking at the themes
damn so no one's policing the content
well all i'm saying is i downloaded all
of them so you can't
you're too late now sony i've already
i'm already too powerful
um so uh on the new on the new uh
redesigned version of the playstation
store you can now pre-order ps5 games
you can't filter settings
uh i feel a listing sorry um there's no
size info
on some of this stuff which is like come
on people want to know that stuff it's
basic stuff
um and you no longer can see like
gameplay and video
uh video gameplay that like you used to
uh in
in the previous version of it which i
kind of liked i used to like hover over
game
game player stuff and see what's going
on um and then the other ones like
titles can't be added
to the cart from a list view and
cardinal sin of design at this at this
stage in 2020 there's no
dark mode what are you doing sony you
gotta have a dark mode option
p some people really need it well if
you're only having you know like a white
ps5 you know maybe that maybe
no darkness no yeah they're just not
committing to dark modes
i hate to see at this point i yeah i'm i
took a look at the new store
i i actually like the new layout but i
the first thought that popped into my
head was oh i would like a
i would like a dark mode it's very
bright
let's move on then uh because trophies
are changing
now we spoke a couple weeks ago about
the changes they were making to the
trophy system last night
uh mine finally ticked over to the new
one i'm kind of enjoying being in the
200s now instead of like
14. um but sony again
bringing back one of xbox's great
features that they seem to have
abandoned
they're like oh that's that's a good
idea and xbox isn't doing it anymore so
mp first living up to their name notice
this first
the fact that if you like look on the ui
walk through some of the
trophies seem to be tied to rewards that
you can use for
avatars and themes and whatnot like
unlocking this trophy
will give you this profile banner or
this profile avatar or something like
that
and that's something that xbox did a lot
in the 360 days like i remember my
avatar being decked out in a bunch of
saints row and mass effect and yeah mine
had
um mine had the normandy and i had like
a cowboy hat from red dead uh and at one
point i had elizabeth's dress from
bioshock infinite
it was nice it was a really cool way of
being able to like see at a glance like
what achievements people had in that
game and i remember making my
avatar for xbox one and just making it a
blank slate i'm like oh i can't wait to
add all the new crazy clothes
options and stuff like that and i don't
know if xbox decided to stop doing that
or if just
developers were just tired of doing that
maybe they were just
more concerned with ensuring that jordan
remain would be screwed over with
achievement numbers that weren't
multiples of five
that was it was a targeted attack on you
but i mean so is this exciting for
anyone else i really like this like i
don't actually really pay attention all
that much to my avatar
on playstation but i might now that
there are
like rewards tied to certain trophies
like
you're you're a playstation person more
than i am lucy like do you
care about this at all i'm more
interested to see
what it will look like because i've had
my
my avatar on playstation for a lot for
the last few years has been
my picture i imported it from facebook
and when they got rid of the integration
i
just uploaded it i did it on the web
version
and so that's what my image is um
profile banners is an interesting one
for me because i really like
taking in-game screenshots and setting
those is my banner right now
um i have all the um the cat toys
from control the ones that do this um
because i spent like three hours doing
that side quest
so i really wanted a photo mode
celebration of it um so i'm interested
to see if we'll still be able to do that
or if everything is going to be locked
uh into destruction all-stars trophies
i think like further gamifying trophies
it's just a smart thing to do
like people are already obsessed with it
and if you're going to give them rewards
beyond like here's a number
um that's really really cool like even
when
the ps4 takes a screenshot the moment
you've got a trophy like
doesn't you get a small kick out of that
because you get to look back and see the
exact moment it happened that's really
cool but now if you're gonna give people
stuff for it i think that's really smart
and
you know bringing back letting people
like customize and letting people like
unlock a platinum and then like
have some meaningful way of being
reminded of that
on their ui or you know when other
people see it i think that's really
really clever and
just a smart thing to do joining us once
again now that the final embargo for
xbox series x is
up we've got our textbook michael hyam
what up y'all it's good to be back yeah
it's great to have you back
so we asked we called out for questions
for you now that you can talk about
pretty much everything to do with the
series x
and boy did the comments deliver so
let's get through them
time to go first so the first question
comes from the twitter user at
games and the gp which i hope stands for
general practitioner um
and not gameplay giant peach
no no no no no no no question about the
xbox
possibly already asked does having a
series x mean you can't have another
xbox one set as your home
xbox can you use both at the same time
games and all and then there's a smiley
hair which is like
half smile which is the creepy one no
it's not the creepy one
it is the creepy one
all right i like this one this one this
is a pleasant smiley
[Laughter]
well i can't see it but what i can see
is the answer to this question
uh which is uh the series x works just
like another xbox so you can set
a one or the series x as your home
console
and it'll function the same way you do
when you set another xbox as your home
console
so i set the series x as the home
console and then
of course you can only sign in as one
account at a time but
setting your home xbox if you know means
that anyone who uses that
xbox can play any of your games that are
loaded onto that system
uh so it works the same way it always
has so you don't need to worry about
having to adjust
your plans of like okay which is going
to be the home xbox so
um yeah you don't have to you don't have
to learn anything new with it it's just
again xbox treats it uh the series x or
the series s
as just another xbox within the same
platform
ecosystem all right michael coming to
you from youtube this is from
e or e or whatever it's just it's just
the letter e so who knows
maybe maybe it's the guy who used to
work for xbox
oh yeah it was oh no was he just j no he
was a e he was the e i think it was e
i'm thinking of philip j fry homogeneous
for everyone yeah
e a c
e a sports it's in the game but coming
from e
what about apps on an hd well you still
need to transfer to the series x
ssd to make them run or will they run
off the hard drive uh they can run off
of a hard drive
actually i just tested this out right
now so i moved uh
crunchyroll my xbox crunchyroll app onto
a hard drive and it works this is just
the same
so you can move apps i think uh there
there might be some
exceptions i don't think i can so
microsoft edge which is the web browser
uh there's
no way to like move it i think it's just
ingrained into the xbox so
i didn't have an option to move that
over to a hard drive but these things
take up such little space that i don't
really see it as a problem but
if you do want to keep all of your like
streaming apps or extraneous apps on
onto a hard drive instead of keeping it
internal you can do that
um you know these aren't these aren't
series x enhanced apps so uh
yeah they'll work straight off of a hard
drive oh so that's got bigger please
tell your friends about this show energy
uh no no one uh seven two three nine
can you use them all at once i assume
these meaning hard drives
like an expansion slot and a bulk usb
drive yeah you can
plug in all of your drives there's three
usb ports i think they're all they're
all usb
super speed uh 3.0 uh and then there's
the expansion slot so you can
technically have four drives
connected to the xbox at once and the
series x will
recognize all those drives at once so
you can use any of the games or apps
that are
in between all those drives no problem
uh
david which is david with a ge after it
asks does
the seagate game drive 4 terabyte
external hard drive portable hdd
designed for xbox one work on the series
x
and if so how fast would it be it only
costs around 100 bucks on amazon which
is why i ask
so i personally don't have the the
seagate game drive that was built
specific
specifically for the xbox one but that
drive will work and it will be treated
as
any other hard drive that's connected to
the series x
and i think we might get into this later
but um if it's already formatted
for xbox one games you don't need to
reformat it so if there's any existing
games on that drive
plug it in series x will recognize all
those things uh
immediately without a problem so um yeah
not only like our accessories all back
and pad but of course
hard drives are treated uh all the same
as long as they are formatted and using
usb 3.0
uh with the series x and in terms of
like how fast would it be
michael's got a write up around the xbox
series x on the site and
what kind of were your takeaways in
terms of using a classic style
hard drive with the series x um
at least when i tested with the series x
the the hard drive that
i did use which was uh western digital
my passport uh that was also a four
terabyte drive
i use a usb 3.0 cable and the load times
were
pretty decent and the transfer speeds
were decent as well the load times were
actually
faster than the internal xbox one x
hard drive and i think this has to do
with the way that the
the series x kind of decompresses and
reads data
off of it which is a lot more efficient
than the xbox one generation
so you will see a benefit there just by
virtue of how the series x is built
and i imagine that if you use that that
same seagate drive that you have been
using with xbox one
you will see some slight improvements
over the series
when you use it on the series x and
series s uh that is
extrapolation based on the data that i
have using my own
hard drive a wild wulu appears asking
i kind of like that i imagine now like
the sword and shield like battle music
playing and an actual like
appearing out of the grass i love this
question i love the idea of a wulu
appearing with questions about xbox 36
michael i have questions a wild wulu
appears asking hey michael any word if
we can use more than one official
external ssd
would be nice if we could slot two one
terabyte ssd cards
nah as as of right now or i guess for
the the foreseeable future these uh the
series x or
the series consoles are going to have
one of the storage expansion slots
specifically for that that one terabyte
expansion card
uh so yeah you can only slot in one i
mean you could
buy multiple i guess if you really want
to ball
out and then just keep uh swapping them
in and out but on the series x and the
series s there's only
one expansion card slot uh of course
like i said you can use usb
drives uh but it's not the same because
you won't be able to play series x and s
games straight off of a usb drive scott
transfer them but
i mean yeah you can only slot in one of
those expansion cards
um but yeah like so far one terabyte's
available i think that's
that's plenty of space it's also kind of
expensive yeah if you ask me but uh yeah
those
that's kind of what that's what you're
working with for now uh alejandro de
paola says
is there information about whether the
oh good lord
xbox series well because he's written it
out xsxx
slash s which not easy to say but the
series x or series s will be compatible
with the connect
2 and the connect adapter for xbox one
s x and if voice commands will still
work on the new generation of consoles
uh connect will not work with the series
x or the series s
as one phil spencer said himself um
yeah there's the series x and series
that's consoles strip just don't
uh they don't they don't play with the
connect so that's unfortunate but i
think it's one of those things that like
microsoft and xbox had to leave behind
in order to move on to the next
generation
um so i guess that's unfortunate for
some but yeah that is the reality of
connect connect is straight up dead
hate to see it next question comes from
the console killer oh
really ominous yes does that make does
it make this person a pc gamer who knows
um great video thank you whatever video
it is that you're referring to it's
michael
yeah michael's video i'm taking it i'm
taking it for this video as well
uh one thing i haven't seen covered i
already have many xbox one games on a
regular external hard drive
well those work on in on the series x or
do i need to format the hard drive and
redownload all of them so you mentioned
this earlier if you want to restate
for clarity sure yeah yeah i mentioned
it uh earlier in
another answer but yes as long as it's
formatted for
the xbox one uh you'll be able to plug
it right into the series x or series s
and it'll work straight up as if you
plugged it into another xbox one so
no need to like redownload or reformat
that drive
so i actually just did that right now i
had final fantasy 15 on an external
drive
i plugged it into my xbox one x or bless
his xbox one x and then
it turned like i was able to play the
game straight off that pulled that out
put into my uh series x was able to play
it off that drive
right then and there uh straight up so
yeah no need to
have to redownload or reformat drives
it's all the same ecosystem so it all
works together
lovely well michael thank you so much
for joining us again to talk about
xbox series x uh and thank you all for
joining us for another episode of
generation next it's so
close to the launch of ps5 and xbox
series snx now so make sure you join us
again
next week bye but i'm not done yet hello
in classic generation next style
something happened after we'd already
finished filming
and the video is almost done in the edit
um
yes we have the playstation 5 we will
tell you everything we know about it as
soon as we can
keep your eyes peeled to generation next
every friday
look at it it's here i can stop
complaining now
[Music]
you